hi everyone this is professor mda
science and today i want to discuss the
virial theorem in another one of our
videos on rigorous quantum mechanics the
virial theorem encodes a simple relation
between the kinetic and potential
energies of any quantum system this
result is immensely powerful because it
holds even for quantum systems for which
we don't have an exact solution and this
means it provides important insights
into complex systems such as atoms
molecules or materials in today's video
we'll derive the virial theorem and then
we'll look at a few examples of his
application let's go
we start with the time independent
hamiltonian h
database this eigenvalue equation
as usual these are the eigenvalues
and these are the eigenstates
it will be useful in a moment to write
this eigenvalue equation in the joule
space
now in general when we go to the joule
space we turn cats into brass as we do
here and here
we should also turn operators into their
adjoints but the hamiltonian is a
hermitian operator so we can write the
hamiltonian here without the adjoint
and we should also turn scalars into
their complex conjugates but the
eigenvalues of a hermitian operator are
real scalars so the energy here is real
and is equal to its complex conjugate
let's also consider a time independent
operator a
we're going to calculate the expectation
value of the commutator of h and a with
respect to an eigenstate of the system
we can expand the commutator using its
definition and we get this expression to
simplify things we can now separate it
into the expectation value of h a
minus the expectation value of a h
using the eigenvalue equation in the
joule space we can now rewrite this term
as the energy eigenvalue times the
eigenvalue
and using the eigenvalue equation in
state space we can write this term
as the energy eigenvalue times the
eigencat
we can take the energy eigenvalues
outside the expectation value to get
this term
minus this term
it is now clear that this expression
vanishes
we have arrived at an important relation
called the hypervirial theorem
it states that the expectation value of
the commutator of the hamiltonian with
any operator a
is equal to zero
and remember that the expectation value
is taken with respect to an energy
eigenstate of the system
without specifying what this operator a
is we get this very general result which
as written is not that useful
what we'll do today is to use the
hypervarial theorem to derive the virial
theorem and to do so we'll make a
specific choice for this operator a
to simplify things let's start by
focusing on a single particle moving in
one dimension in this context we can
write the hamiltonian h
as equal to the usual kinetic energy
operator
plus a general potential energy that
depends on the position operator
to simplify notation we'll occasionally
rewrite the kinetic energy with a
capital t operator
and the potential energy with a capital
v operator without specifying the
dependence on the position operator
to make progress we're now going to use
a specific operator a
equal to the product of the position and
momentum operators
to use the hypervision theorem at the
top we'll need to evaluate this
commutator in our case this is the
commutator of h with xp
remember from the video on commutator
algebra link in the description that the
commutator of an operator x
with the product of two operators y and
z
is equal to this first term
plus the second term
using this expression we can rewrite our
commutator as x times the commutator of
h and p
plus the commutator of h and x times p
let's start with this first commutator
which we can write here
expanding the hamiltonian we can rewrite
the commutator as the sum of these two
terms
the first term vanishes because the
momentum operator commutes with any
power of itself
for the second term remember from the
video on functions of operators that the
commutator of any function f of the
position operator with the momentum
operator
is equal to i h bar times the derivative
of f
using this result we can rewrite our
commutator as i h bar times the
derivative of the potential
moving to the second commutator up here
we also start by copying it down
we again expand the hamiltonian and get
these two commutators
the second commutator vanishes because x
commutes with any function of x
for the first commutator we can again
use this relation up here to expand it
into this pre-factor
this first term
and the second term
this commutator is equal to minus ih bar
and so is this one
overall we end up with minus i h bar
over m
times the momentum operator
let's make some room
using the results we just got we can
write the commutator of the hamiltonian
with xp as equal to i h bar x times the
derivative of the potential
minus i h bar over m times the momentum
squared
all we've done is literally to replace
the commutators here and here with the
results we got in the previous slide but
feel free to pause here to cross check
this step
moving on we can rearrange the
expression to take ih bar out as a
common factor
multiplying x times the derivative of
the potential
and then i'm conveniently regrouping the
term that depends on the momentum squat
this term in brackets is simply the
kinetic energy operator
so we can rewrite the whole expression
in this more compact form
we can now use this result for the
commutator
and insert it into the expression for
the hypervarial theorem
with this we get i h bar times the
expectation value of x times the
derivative of the potential
minus two i h bar times the expectation
value of the kinetic energy operator
all equal to zero
and we have now arrived at the virial
theorem
the expectation value of x times the
derivative of the potential
is equal to 2 times the expectation
value of the kinetic energy
it is very important to remember that
the viral theorem only applies when the
expectation value is evaluated with
respect to an energy eigenstate and this
is why so far i've written all
expectation values with the explicit
eigenstates for example here and here
however moving forward we'll simplify
notation and write expectation values in
the usual shorthand which means that the
viral theorem becomes this
we'll just have to remember that we're
calculating these expectation values
with respect to the energy eigenstates
of the system
let's now try to understand a bit more
what the virial theorem means
it provides a very general relationship
between the expectation values of
potential
and kinetic energies
without the need to explicitly evaluate
them
evaluating expectation values can be
tedious for example it may require long
integrals if we work in the position
representation in terms of wavefunctions
on top of that most quantum systems
cannot be solved analytically which
means that we often have to work with
approximate solutions
in all these cases the viral theorem
becomes a very powerful and useful
result it provides an exact relation
that can help us explore some properties
of the system even if we don't have a
full solution or it can also help us
understand the quality of any
approximate solutions we may have
interestingly there is also a viral
theorem in classical mechanics
the result is analogous to the one we
just obtained in quantum mechanics
two times the time average of the
kinetic energy
is equal to the time average of x times
the derivative of the potential
now i'm using the same symbol of angle
brackets but the meaning in classical
mechanics is that of a time average
in classical mechanics we know that the
force acting on a system is equal to the
negative gradient of the potential
so we can also rewrite the classical
viral theorem using the negative time
average of x times the force
and this is actually where the name
virial in viral theorem comes from
specifically from the latin word this
which means force
the virial theorem takes a rather simple
form for a special class of potentials
and this is what we'll investigate next
specifically we're going to consider
potentials that are described by a
special type of function
called a homogeneous function of degree
k
by definition a homogeneous function f
of degree k
is one for which f of s x
is equal to s to the power k times f of
x
and where s is a non-zero scalar
as an example of a homogeneous function
we can consider a quadratic function
where lambda is simply scalar
coefficient
in this case we can explicitly confirm
that f of s x
is equal to this
which you can rewrite as s squared times
lambda x squared
which in turn is equal to s squared
times f of x
given that we have a power of 2 here we
can conclude that the quadratic function
is a homogeneous function of degree 2.
we also need an important result
associated with homogeneous functions
called euler's theorem
it states that for a continuously
differentiable homogeneous function of
degree k
then k times f of x
is equal to x times the derivative of f
the proof of this result is very simple
starting with the definition of a
homogeneous function of degree k here
for the proof we need to calculate the
derivative with respect to s
let's first evaluate the derivative of
the left hand side
using the chain rule we get the
derivative of f with respect to s x
times the derivative of s x with respect
to s
this here is simply x
so we can rewrite this derivative as x
times the derivative of f with respect
to s x
for the right hand side we get the
derivative of this expression
which is simply the derivative of the
power
times f of x
equating these two sides
we get this expression involving the
derivative of f
as equal to this other expression
involving f
finally setting s equal to 1 gives us
euler theorem up here
all of these ideas can be easily
generalized to multivariable functions
and will explicitly show the
corresponding results later on in the
video
we are now ready to rewrite the virial
theorem for potentials that correspond
to homogeneous functions
if the potential v is described by a
homogeneous function of degree k then by
definition it obeys this relation
using euler's theorem we can then
conclude that k times the potential
is equal to x times the derivative of
the potential
we can now insert this result
inside the virial theorem up here
and this takes us to the variable
theorem for potentials described by
homogeneous functions of degree k
we have that k
times the expectation value of the
potential energy
is equal to 2 times the expectation
value of the kinetic energy
as promised this new expression provides
a simple form for the video theorem in
the special case when the potential is
described by a homogeneous function
now this expression for the video
theorem can be rewritten in a few
alternative forms
remember that the variable theorem
applies when we take the expectation
value with respect to an energy
eigenstate
if we consider the expectation value of
the hamiltonian
and i will explicitly write it out with
respect to eigenstate n
then it is simply equal to the
eigenvalue e n
note that as the hamiltonian is the sum
of kinetic and potential energies we can
also rewrite this as the sum of the
expectation value of the kinetic energy
and the expectation value of the
potential energy
we now have two equations relating the
expectation values of the kinetic and
potential energies the first one is the
viral theorem up here
and the second is this one here
that describes the fact that the total
energy of the system is equal to the sum
of the kinetic and potential energies
from these two equations we can isolate
the expectation value of either kinetic
or potential energies
i'll leave it as an exercise for you but
it should be easy to confirm that we get
the expectation value of the kinetic
energy
as equal to k
e n
over k plus 2
and we get the expectation value of the
potential energy
as equal to 2 e n
over k plus 2.
now while these results are rather neat
you may be wondering how relevant they
are as they only apply when the
potential is described by a homogeneous
function
well as we'll see in a moment there are
plenty of very important potentials that
are described by homogeneous functions
to consider an example of the virial
theorem for a potential described by a
homogeneous function let's consider the
quantum harmonic oscillator
remember that in this case the
hamiltonian h
is equal to the usual kinetic energy
plus a potential energy which depends
quadratically on the position
operator we've already discussed earlier
that the quadratic function is a
homogeneous function of degree 2 and you
can easily confirm that this is the case
for the potential of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
using the viral theorem we can then
immediately conclude that for the
quantum harmonic oscillator in any
energy eigenstate
the expectation value of the potential
energy
is equal to the expectation value of the
kinetic energy
and this is an example of the power of
the virial theorem
we can reach this result without having
to solve the quantum harmonic oscillator
problem all we need to know is the form
of the potential
in the case of the quantum harmonic
oscillator we do actually know how to
solve the problem and i encourage you to
confirm this result explicitly however
as we discussed earlier there are many
quantum problems for which we don't have
an analytical solution but the viral
theorem still applies in those cases
even though our discussion so far has
been limited to a single particle moving
in 1d we have in fact already covered
all the important aspects of the virial
theorem
moving to 3d and moving to
multi-particle systems is a simple
generalization of this discussion and to
finish the video i'll quickly describe
some of the key results and you can fill
in the gaps yourself
we consider a system with n particles
whose positions are described by the
vector operator r which is given by the
three components x
y and z
these particles are also characterized
by their momentum operator p
with components px
py
and pz
the sub indices i here and here label
the different particles and i runs from
1 to n
for this system we can write the
hamiltonian h
as equal to the sum of the kinetic
energy operators for each particle
plus the potential energy which in
general depend on the positions of all
particles
again we'll conveniently label this term
as the kinetic energy t
and this term has the potential energy v
following the same strategy we use for a
single particle moving in 1d we can
write the virial theorem
as the expectation value of this sum
over the product of the position
operator and the gradient of the
potential
being equal to 2 times the expectation
value of the kinetic energy operator
just like in the single particle 1d case
many important potentials have the form
of a homogeneous function and this
expression for the video theorem can be
simplified further in those cases
and this is what we'll explore next
very briefly we can generalize the
definition of a homogeneous function of
degree k to functions of multiple
variables the definition is that when we
scale every single one of the variables
by the same scalar s
and here we consider a function f of n
variables
then we get s to the power k
times the original function
and remember that s is a non-zero scalar
we can also generalize euler's theorem
the derivation is completely analogous
to the one we provided for the single
variable case and euler's theorem states
that k times f
is equal to the sum of x times the
derivative of f with respect to x
with the results we've just discussed
and using the same argument we use for
one particle in 1d we can now consider
the virial theorem for a multi-particle
system described by a potential that is
a homogeneous function of degree k
we have that k times the expectation
value of the potential energy operator
is equal to two times the expectation
value of the kinetic energy operator
let's consider two quick examples
the first is for the hydrogen atom which
is a two particle system in 3d
we have a full series on the hydrogen
atom and i recommend you check it out by
following the relevant links in the
description but what matters for our
purposes today is that the potential
energy of the hydrogen atom is given by
the electrostatic interaction between a
proton
and an electron
and it takes its usual form
note that here we're considering a
non-relativistic hydrogen atom
spelling this out we see that the
potential energy is a function of six
variables
and explicitly we can write it out in
this long form
feel free to pause here to cross check
this but all we've done is to spell out
the distance between the proton and
electron in the denominator
moving on with this expression it's easy
to confirm that the potential function
obeys this relation when we multiply the
arguments by scalar s
the exponent here
means that this is a homogeneous
function of degree minus one
now we haven't done this explicitly but
it's a good exercise so feel free to try
it out
but now we come to the key point
without the need to find the hydrogen
atom eigenvalues or eigenstates we can
immediately use the viral theorem to
write that for any energy eigenstate the
expectation value of the potential
energy
is equal to -2 times the expectation
value of the kinetic energy
now the hydrogen atom together with the
harmonic oscillator is one of the very
few quantum mechanical systems for which
we have a full analytical solution
in fact in the video link in the
description on the ground state of the
hydrogen atom we explicitly calculate
these expectation values and confirm the
variable theorem
however to get to this result using the
full solution is a rather tedious
process as solving the hydrogen atom
eigenvalue problem isn't trivial by
contrast using the visual theorem we can
get to this same conclusion without any
knowledge of the precise form of the
hydrogen atom eigenvalues or
eigenfunctions
let's make some room
and consider a second example which will
be a very general quantum system an atom
a molecule or a material
all these systems are made of a single
atom or of a collection of atoms
in turn these atoms are made of a
collection of atomic nuclei and
electrons
however
irrespective of how complex the system
is or of how many particles it has
the potential energy terms always have
the same form
ignoring relativistic effects again the
component particles all interact by an
electrostatic interaction an interaction
v between any two particles one and two
takes the same general form
we have the usual pre-factor
and then the product of the electric
charges
over the distance between the two
particles
as this form is the same we had earlier
between interacting proton and electron
in a hydrogen atom we can immediately
conclude that these tubal interaction
terms obey this relation
and are therefore homogeneous functions
of degree minus one
the total potential energy of a
multi-particle system is the sum of the
individual two body terms so the total
potential energy is also a homogeneous
function of degree minus one
we can therefore use the variable
theorem to conclude that for any
eigenstate of any of these systems the
expectation value of the potential
energy
is equal to -2 times the expectation
value of the kinetic energy
this is a very general result and again
we have been able to obtain it without
having to first solve the eigenvalue
equation of the hamiltonian to determine
the eigenvalues or eigenstates
unlike hydrogen for any of these systems
it is impossible to exactly calculate
the energy eigenvalues or eigenstates
the virial theorem then tells us that
whatever form the unknown solution of
the problem takes
it must obey these relation
the virial theorem is a very neat
mathematical result that allows us to
understand some key properties of any
quantum system even if we don't have a
full mathematical solution as a
follow-up i recommend that you check out
the video on the ground state of the
hydrogen atom in that video we can
demonstrate analytically that the video
theorem is satisfied and as always if
you like the video please subscribe